hi everybody I'm Erik Bosse and we here
at new rock stars have been rewatching
past episodes of Game of Thrones to
uncover interesting details and
connections we missed the first time
around and for me the Viserys golden
ground scene was the first time this
series twisted our arm and forced us to
pay it some respect you know like how
Khal Drogo did of his Aires it really
launched a trend of Game of Thrones what
the moments that pans make reaction
videos about oh so over this video I
thought we'd dive deep into just this
epic moment those subtle details that
made it great but also the cool ways
this series led up to it and ultimately
its legacy
how did Viserys his death serve as a
warning for Danny of the trials ahead
spoilers ahead for all episodes of Game
of Thrones which I have to say because
for some people their decision to click
on a video about the most popular show
on TV that they somehow haven't seen is
my fault okay here we go
first let's break down what happens here
Daenerys Viserys Sir Jorah Drogo in the
Dothraki horde are celebrating in the
sacred city of Vasto threat Dany is
pregnant with Drogo's baby and according
to Dothraki believe her success at
devouring an entire horse heart means
the baby will be a healthy boy a
stallion that mounts the world the
respect that Dany earns infuriates
Viserys who after trying to steal her
dragon eggs drunkenly pulls his sword on
them all a huge no-no envious Dothraki
where weapons are forbidden and demands
the crown he was promised so Drogo
breaks his arm and gives him one this
moment is actually the culmination of a
series of events a critical turning
point in Danny's journey in which she
simultaneously severs ties with her
brother and absorbs his ambitions into
her own trajectory let's look back at
episode 1 back in Pentos when Viserys
threatened his sister you don't the weak
the dragon deep but after Viserys leaves
Dany steps into the scalding hot bath
it's too hot my lady her calm reaction
here was the first indicator that Danny
truly does have the blood of the Dragon
meanwhile a few episodes later when
bazzara shares a bath with Doria a small
moment reveals that his skin is a lot
thinner melted like so many candles wow
this episode reminds us of this earlier
in the episode when Danny as if in a
trance roasts her dragon egg on the
coals remaining unburned while her maid
gets scarred so today versus final line
here is really the final step of that
comparison between the siblings he's no
trackin fire cannot kill that dragon
this progression was also expressed
through Danny's hair which if you've
been watching closely had been gradually
transitioning her from tear garyun run
away to Dothraki Khaleesi back in
episode 3 Danny's hair begins to get
braided in the Dothraki style
jakka you change Khaleesi that Dothraki
word that she's trying to pronounce
atcha huh car translates to pride it's
derived from their word to hawk which is
the name of the long braids that
Dothraki warriors wear a symbol of their
pride the completion of Danny's braid
this episode and its progression
throughout the series reflects her
increasing pride and strength as a
character actually Danny consuming the
horse heart this episode is in a way her
consuming her brother as a character
notice what Viserys says they watch
isn't discussed cooked on Mongols
Viserys is suddenly fearful that his
sister producing a male heir will oust
him from the line of succession and
jealous that his sister has received the
love that he's always demanded but never
received so his abrupt disappearance
from the end of this heart eating scene
foreshadows his abrupt removal from the
series this episode it's not the heart
of viz heiresses horse that Danny is
eating here on a symbolic level she's
devouring Viserys his heart I'm gonna be
the one to leave the Dothraki Army back
to Westeros not you eat your heart out
bro of course Viserys does finally do
something to command the Dothraki 'aa
tension he directly threatens Drogo and
Danny's unborn baby but unlike his
sister he commands respect in a way that
insults the Dothraki customs on their
own turf so the crown he receives is
really only an ironic one there are a
few elements in the scene
really make it unforgettable first are
the performances Harry Lloyd joke that
he watched videos from YouTube to
perfect his drunken walk but it's really
his eyes that do the talking as his
sister translates Drogo's promised to
give him a golden crown that men will
tremble to behold Lloyd's resolve
crumbles into a teary-eyed vulnerability
in naivete like a child unaware of how
much trouble he's in it's interesting to
hear Viserys call his sister Danny
please throughout the show in the book
she usually goes by Daenerys the
shortened Dany is really only reserved
for the books of course over time
Daenerys adopts many names and titles
but I love the implication that it's her
brother's familial nickname / er that
she goes by within her own mind the name
he screamed at her when begging for his
life and she did nothing I mean just
look at Emilia Clarke's eyes here
they've hearted into this steely glazed
over expression the moment her brother
threatens her baby all love is lost for
this despicable prat honestly after six
episodes of this guy a gruesome death is
just what the doctor ordered they pulled
off this stunt practically and one takes
since the liquid would ruin his heirs
his costume they use smoked emitters
strapped to Harry Lloyd's back and then
they switch to a bald cap with a mold
for the return shot when the gold
hardened by the way if you were
wondering how Drogo's gold melted and re
hardened so quickly
apparently Dothraki gold is a cheaper
alloy containing less precious metals
making it more malleable and Noble also
this seamless sucked if it took like an
hour for the golden Elsa to show really
it's the sound editing that sells all
this when Viserys pulls a sword that
thumping at the Dothraki drums cuts off
replaced by hisses of the women cursing
Viserys for unsheathing his sword in the
sacred city and then there's a sudden
snap of bones in his arm and the hissing
and bubbling of a liquid gold as bizarre
as his screams go horse
[Applause]
and then finally there's the perfect
metallic clink as a hit hits the ground
this little detail is a perfect
expression of the deeper meaning that
runs throughout Game of Thrones the
Shakespearean notion of heavy lies the
crown the idea that being a king is more
of a burden than an opportunity the
crown ultimately just weighs you down so
Bezerra says golden crowns serving as
his own brutal end is really just the
first of many Regicides in the show
Robert Renly Robb Joffrey's Stannis
Balin Tommen like in chess the kings of
Kamath Thrones are the most vulnerable
of course vizars''-- death it's also
just the first of many horrific shocking
deaths of main characters that would
give Game of Thrones his bloody
reputation but this moment lives on with
Dany and some interesting ways like her
ever growing to hawk brave Dany later on
uses her wardrobe to evoke her dead
brothers ambition to retake the Iron
Throne in season 7 when she returns to
their ancestral home of Dragonstone her
black and crimson clothes were designed
to paralleled the clothes once worn by
Viserys that restoration mission began
in this moment a mission consumed from
her brother it's also interesting how
later on she loses her dragon vis area
the one she named after Vaziri
so she pays the heavy cost of his Ariane
to save her love interest in that moment
paralleling her decision to allow
vissarion's namesake to die to pursue
her previous love but one of those
interesting parallels comes up in this
little exchange between Danny and Jorah
look away khaleesi her insistence on
witnessing this echoes the first episode
when bran has to witness the execution
and that moment bran was learning what a
just execution was and he needed to see
it to understand
similarly Dany has to watch the man
she's sentenced to death executed so
that she can one day learn the true
weight of justice that's a burden she'll
struggle with when she orders executions
in Meereen and recently in Westeros when
she set the tarly's ablaze that
unforgettable metallic thud could be
seen as a kind of warning bell for Dany
haunting her throughout these impossible
decisions as she gradually learns a
lesson that her brother only learned at
the last second heavy lies the crown a
question for you guys how does Vizier is
his death ranked for you among the
deaths of other despicable villains like
Joffrey Ramsay Tywin Walder Frey or
Littlefinger to me all those left me
with Barry
degrees of emotional payoff but yeah you
can't just beat the original moment of
the series where we're all like yeah
comment with your ranking down below and
let me know what other big moments from
this series you'd like to see us analyze
like we did here rather than going to be
stood by episode some of which are
honestly a bit less memorable than
others we're considering just going more
in depth on the singular moments from
the past that we all still talk about
hardhome mountain versus a viper that
weird scene with Varys and the wizard in
the Bark's so let us know what moments
you want broken down in the comments you
can also tweet me directly at EI vos and
follow two rock stars on twitter at new
rockstars for updates on our videos like
this video and subscribe to new
rockstars for more Game of Thrones deep
dives including analyses of every
episode of season 6 and 7 predictions
for season 8 and coverage of other
series like Westworld and stranger
things and if you really like us you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially
Wilhelmina eveson thanks for watching
guys bye